Steve: Hello everyone,
This is Steve.
Steve: Today, I am speaking in Japanese.
And We have a special guest.
Steve: Mr,Kazu from Kazu languages
Kazu: Hi everyone,
Steve: Hello,
So if you like my videos
Steve: Please subscribe my channel.
Steve: Today, I would like to
Have an interview with Kazu.
Steve: Because he is able to
speak various languages.
Steve: I lived in Japan for 9 years.
Steve: When I went to book stores,
I saw only English text book.
Steve: Learning other languages
it was always only English,
Steve: And little bit of Chinese,
Spanish, Korean, That was how it was.
Steve: Then, It was told that
Steve: Japanese people don’t care
about other languages except English.
Steve: But Mr,Kazu
Could you please introduce
Steve: about your channel and
Steve: explain which languages
You’ve studied.
Steve: To my audience.
Kazu: My main reason for studying
other languages is
Kazu: to communicate with
other people and make friends.
Kazu: Learning new languages will
empower me to learn more about other cultures.
Kazu: To see how people react to
What you speak.
Kazu: And by leaning those languages
Kazu: I believe there’s a connection
between leaning and respecting their cultures.
Kazu: In my channel,
I am having conversations with
Kazu: various people from different countries
in their mother language.
Kazu: Now, I am able to speak Japanese,
English, Spanish, French, Portuguese,
Kazu: Indonesian, Russian, Arabic,
Those are the languages I am studying now.
Steve: Interesting thing is
Steve: Romance languages,
For example French, Italian, Portuguese,
Steve: These are easy.
Kazu: But in your case,
Slavic languages like Indonesian, Arabic,
Steve: and Languages in Europe,
Your interest is wide range.
Steve: How do you choose to study
those languages?
Kazu: There’s very important point
Kazu: when I decide to study new languages
That is I want to study
Languages that’s completely opposite
Kazu: to my lifestyle.
Kazu: For example,
Difference of cultures from my standpoint.
Kazu: or difference of lifestyles,
I want to study languages
Kazu: That has different cultures from Japan
Kazu: So I am intentionally choosing
languages that is other group of language family.
Kazu: I am choosing widely
Kazu: so I’ll have opportunity to
learn about many other countries.
Steve: When you visit Europe.
Steve: There’s some like..
Steve: People gather at pub
Steve: And put national flags
on their chest that they are able to speak
Steve: and have conversations with
various languages
Steve: sometimes swap their seats,
There’s things like that.
Steve: Of course, There’s other languages
right next to your country in Europe.
Steve: So there are many people
Who is able to speak other languages.
Steve: How about Japan?
Steve: Is there any movement of people
Steve: like wanting to study
various languages?
Steve: Is there anything like that?
Kazu: Well.. There are not much
in Japan yet, But
Kazu: People’s attention to
English has been increased
Kazu: Long time ago, Japanese was told that
We are the nation not good at speaking other languages
Kazu: But things changed
Kazu: There are many people
Whom taking English class seriously
Kazu: Another example is,
Some people choose to study
Kazu: Spanish, Chinese and other languages
Kazu: as second language at the college.
Kazu: I sense that people are
starting to change
Kazu: Their attitude toward Languages.
Steve: English or Spanish, Russian..
Steve: There’s this thing called
comprehensible input.
Steve: There are many
interesting contents
Steve: like podcast,
Steve: or TV channels,
There are many of them.
Steve: In my case,
I am having difficult time with Arabic.
Steve: I am struggling.
Steve: To find right audio and text books
Steve: for my level.
Steve: It’s difficult to find them.
Steve: So, I have no idea
about Indonesian.
Steve: How do you find
materials to study
Steve: Indonesian and Arabic
Steve: That matches to your level and
Steve: gives you interest into it?
Steve: Are you having difficult time?
Kazu: Well, Yes, It’s very difficult
Kazu: Especially finding
Egyptian dialect in Arabic.
Kazu: There’s no such a thing on the internet.
Kazu: So…
Kazu: Mainly I watch
YouTube and Netflix.
Steve: Certainly,
YouTube is the best source.
Kazu: Yes, I agree with you.
Steve: There are many Lebanese as well.
Kazu: Ah Lebanese, Yes.
Steve: I get confused between
Lebanese and Arabic.
Steve: Sometimes I listen to
Lebanese and Egyptian.
Steve: And listen to standard Arabic,
These are very difficult.
Kazu: There are so many various languages.
Steve: Yes.
Steve: So, Do you live in Japan?
Kazu: Yes, I live in Japan
for most of my life.
Steve: Are you planning to
visit abroad ?
Kazu: Well, For now I want to focus on
studying languages.
Kazu: But maybe next year or
the year after next
Kazu: I want to visit countries
where main languages are
Kazu: What I  learned.
Steve: That makes scene.
Steve: The thing about trip like that
Steve: When you visit those countries
Steve: After you study hard
Steve: It’s like a dream… like a dream.
Kazu: Certainly, It is special.
Steve: Being able to use
Steve: languages that you studied hard
Steve: In your daily life
Steve: Is such a special thing.
Kazu: Yes.
Steve: Is there any particular countries,
Like South America or Europe or Russia
Steve: Or Egypt,
Closest to Indonesia.
Kazu: Well
Kazu: First, Since I have lot of friends
in Indonesia, So I want to visit there.
Kazu: And I studied both
Portuguese and Spanish
Kazu: so I want to visit South America as well,
I just want to see whole world.
Steve: Very well then.
Steve: I think
Steve: Anybody should be able to
learn multiple languages
Steve: Not only one language,
Steve: And there’s such a great
technologies like MP3 and others,
Steve: So we are able to study
much easier than how it used to be.
Steve: And your life will get richer.
Steve: So I could say that
you are a discoverer
Steve: of languages.
Kazu: Discoverer.
Kazu: I am humbled.
Steve: OK, so.
Steve: I will leave link
of your YouTube channel
Steve: Into description box.
[Speaking Spanish］
Steve: So far, What I could understand is
Steve: Only Bahasa Indonesia!
Steve: I’ll study Indonesian
in the future.
Steve: OK! Thank you.
Steve: That was fun.
Steve: I wish you all the best.
Kazu: Thank you.
Steve: Please study
10 and 20 more languages
Steve: Since you are so much younger than me.
Kazu: Yes, I will do my best. Thank you so much.
Steve: Thank you, Bye bye.